history
next in this encore book notes from 1994
historian claire brandt talks about her
biography of benedict arnold the
revolutionary war commander who became a
spy ms brandt asserts that arnold
suffered from insecurity caused by the
adolescent trauma of having an alcoholic
father who went bankrupt it's about an
hour
claire brandt when did you first get
interested in benedict arnold
oh probably in third grade when i found
out what a dastardly traitor he was
uh then i called my
enemies on the playground by that name
as we all did i guess in those days no i
got interested in him when i
it was actually my husband's idea to do
the book and the minute he said the word
i knew that's who i wanted to write
about and i couldn't possibly tell you
why but the minute i started doing a
little bit of research i got absolutely
intrigued because i wanted to know why
you did it
like a detective story here was this
able
intelligent
marvelous soldier great leader of men
very articulate in the cause of his
country why in the world did this man
give it all up and turn his coat and i
had to know why i got totally hooked is
this your first book no second book i
wrote a history of the livingston family
of the hudson valley called an american
aristocracy which was published in 1986.
and that was my first book this is my
third career so
what were your other careers i was an
actor
at when i first came out of college and
then that of course didn't put any bread
on the table so i became a teacher and i
taught acting and drama and then
eventually got into teaching history
by way of theater history first and then
just got intrigued with the whole thing
and the minute i decided i was a little
burned out on teaching i decided to
write where did you teach
i taught in independent schools in
boston and in new york at the high
school level i don't have a teacher's
degree i've never taken an education
course in my life so that i wouldn't
they wouldn't let me in a public school
where do you live now i live in
rhinebeck new york just north of 90
miles north of new york city in the
hudson valley
so this all works then yes it's very
near west point it's very exciting to be
on that river well it's a beautiful
river anyway but i was able to went to
uh to get someone local to take me in a
boat and retrace arnold's steps when he
made that hair-raising escape from
george washington uh to the british ship
in haverstraw bay i was able to do that
with the same kind of a tide with a stop
watch and figure out how fast they rode
and all those all that kind of thing
which was a lot of fun and of course
west point itself is very interesting
when did you start the book
took me six years to write a research
and write so a long time ago i've been
living and breathing with this man for a
very long time
when was he born
1741
in norwich connecticut son of a
prosperous merchant and trader uh very
high standing in the community norwich
was then one of the biggest towns in
connecticut and like every other town in
new england it was full of traders
international traders who were trading
to quebec into europe and down to the
caribbean
and arnold's father was one of them um
he had various siblings
and then
when he was 10 his other brother died
and he was then the only son and he was
sent away to a classical boarding
academy in a town just a few miles
upriver
which was a rarity in the colonies
having a classical education and of
course going on to college which he
probably would have done from that
school was even rarer still so he was
well on his way
up to a higher status of society i
suppose and certainly of intelligence or
intellectualism than even his own
parents
but then when he was 14
yanked back home again papa had become
an alcoholic and had gone bankrupt so
there was no money for the education
no business for arnold to inherit and
run when he got through school and he
was put as an apprentice to an
apothecary
quite a comedy i remember you writing
somebody uh benedict arnold was born and
then died
was he the one that then oh no he had an
older brother benedict who died as an
infant
uh this was common practice in in the
18th century that if that you gave the
next child of the same gender the same
name that you had given the dead baby
this is i'm sure had to do with wanting
to pass family names down uh his
father's name was benedict and his
grandfather's name was benedict and so
forth so they obviously wanted to keep
the name so when the first born benedict
died as an infant then the next son
would have automatically received that
name
see if he were 14 to be about 1755 if i
can't write what was this country all
about in 1755 well it was before the end
of the french and indian wars so that
was still going on not of course in
connecticut although
there were a lot of people who went to
it uh as british soldiers of course
there are even some other historians
have said other biographers have said
that arnold ran away
and went
and joined up and went to the french and
indian wars i've looked at that evidence
very carefully and decided that it
wasn't him that it was somebody else
i don't think he did do that
so the country was very much um in flux
but the british of course were firmly in
control now because the french were no
longer in canada and it was at peace for
the first time in a long time which must
have been a big relief and very
prosperous business boom the way it
often does after a war and the british
of course then
decided that now that they had canada to
administer as well
they needed some more money from these
colonies over across the water and
that's when they began to enforce the
laws that were already on the books
about trading and that's when arnold who
by the age of 21 had become an
independent trader and merchant in new
haven he'd been such a he'd been such a
good apprentice that the the men he'd
worked for set him up
loaned him the money um
all the traders in new england started
to go broke because they could no longer
trade directly with quebec and the
caribbean without being um
interdicted by british ships on the high
seas all their all their cargo's taken
and they were they in fact were turned
into smugglers
when you lived in this country say when
he was 21 then make it what 1762
uh
what country were you a citizen of or oh
great well you were you were yeah great
britain you were you were a british
citizen held a british passport i
suppose so yes how many people lived
here in 1760 i'm afraid i can't tell you
that but it wasn't very many it was a
very small society people knew people in
other
in other cities
by reputation if nothing else certainly
every town everybody sort of knew
everybody no matter how big it was um it
was a much smaller society let me jump
to kind of the end of the story for
someone that has not studied benedict
arnold
what's all the fuss about and you and
the title is the man in the mirror
where did you get that title
i got it from
the image that i ended
up really hanging the whole
story on
i came to believe
that that that the experience that he
had when he was a young man
was very definitive for him although he
made a grand success of his
apprenticeship and of his later business
dealings that underneath he was a very
very insecure person who was very
frightened of losing status very
frightened of never not having enough
money and this grew into a kind of a he
became terribly self-protective of
himself and then when the war came along
and he became a public hero which he did
quite quickly
um
the pressure on him was enormous to
maintain that image of the patriot and
the hero
he could not broke criticism he had a he
had a very thin skin and my contention
is that to make a long story short is
much more complicated than this of
course that he built himself a house of
mirrors which would protect him from the
outside world and would show him to
himself the way he wished to be
so that's really the central image of
the book because i think that was the
guiding factor in arnold's life
how big was he
five foot nine ish is is as close as i
can come he was sort of stocky
um
not handsome i don't think i think he
could be very attractive when he wanted
to be i think he could be very charming
when he wanted to be the illustration
which is the frontal piece in the book
is the only portrait that is known to be
taken from life there are other
portraits of him but they don't look
much like this and i will go with this
one every time because it was done
during the war and taken i mean he sat
for it where'd you get this the portrait
um i'm not sure where the original is
this is an engraving done from the
original which i got at the new york
historical society
now when you set out to um
to investigate i mean in the back you've
got this huge bibliography and all these
sorts notes and all that stuff where did
you go
to find out about benedict arnold um i
started well i don't even know where i
started i started reading some other
biographies that had been written in the
past
and then as all good historians do i
strip mine their bibliographies which is
one way to start i started asking around
i went to the libraries where i'd worked
before new york public library new york
historical
and
one thing leads to another leads to
another leads to another and you find
yourself just following your nose i
ended up going to england to the public
record office to read all the all the
british
stuff about him and about the battles
that he'd fought when he was a british
officer and of course i went to
philadelphia where he was commandant i
also went all the places where he fought
battles
and went up the kennebec river not every
square inch of it but a lot of it i went
up and went to quebec in january just to
see how cold it was it's cold
because that's very important to me i
think it's important to know what it's
what it feels like to be in that place
as close as you can get to it so i try
to i try to go the places and i try to
go with the right season of the year how
many times was he married twice
how many children did he have he had a
total of eight survivors there were some
babies that died young uh three by the
first wife who was a new haven woman
whom he married before the war she died
right at the beginning of the war and
then
five surviving ones by his second wife
peggy shippen of philadelphia
19 year old gorgeous philadelphia bell
and i'm looking for a map here so we
could get some sense of where all this
is and this this is one of the earliest
illustrations yeah that's lake champlain
where he fought uh
two of his decisive battles the first
well the first one wasn't really a
battle when he took over
uh ticonderoga with ethan allen in 1775
but then later after the
after he'd led the march up the kennebec
and they'd attacked quebec and not taken
it and they finally eventually had to
get out of canada
um the british decided that they wanted
to come down or rather up lake champlain
since its flows north and attack the
hudson river and take over the hudson
river and sever washington's
communications with new england not be
able to use those hudson river crossings
which were crucial for just for the
logistics of the army and supplying the
army
so they were going to do that in 76 the
american army was on the run out of
canada decimated by smallpox it was a
hideous retreat but the success of the
retreat the fact that they brought
anybody out was in great part due to
benedict arnold he was superb at that
kind of thing once he realized he had to
get out he knew how to do it and he knew
how to take care of his men
so they limped into ticonderoga
uh with the british then paused at the
at the northern end of the lake and it
was assumed that they were going to sail
south and attack ticonderoga
before too many weeks went by so that
they would then have time before the
winter set in to get through to albany
establish themselves there and then in
the spring meet up with british troops
from new york and take the hudson valley
under their control
so what they decided to do arnold and
his superior officers phillip schuyler
and horatio gates at ticonderoga
that spring early summer was to build a
fleet
to try to stop the british
and arnold was largely responsible of
that he was given command of
constructing the fleet and then
eventually given command of it and he
constructed i mean all these be banged
together boats gondolas not a not a
venetian gondola of course but a a war
gondola
and um a couple of um
lots of bateaus and rowing boats and
things like that lake champlain is an
incredible place to try to sail because
you've got big high mountains on both
sides so you need very maneuverable
boats and he didn't have time to build
very maneuverable boats but he smashed
together this rather makeshift little
fleet they didn't have enough
rope they didn't have enough sails they
didn't have anybody who knew how to sail
a boat except for arnold he did know how
to sail a boat because he'd been a
traitor before the war and had sailed to
the caribbean
um but he was practically the only one
well not that's not true but he was
among the very few people in that fleet
who knew how to sail who knew how to
point a gun on a heaving deck who knew
how to do any of those things
and he
went he did a couple of recon ordering
uh expeditions with his little fleet up
into the lake and eventually the british
did come down
uh he was he had put himself behind an
island and they sailed past him before
they realized he was there
then they had to beat back up wind to
get at him and he was able to take them
on one or one one and two at a time
and fight them off the first day but
they had this enormous ship called
inflexible which they had taken down
they brought it over from england taken
it down brought it around into the lake
and rebuilt it at the top of the lake
that's what had taken them so long they
didn't come down till october everybody
was expecting them in august they didn't
come till october because they wanted to
wait
to get this big ship built and the
reason they wanted to wait to get this
big ship built was that they heard that
benedict arnold was building a fleet and
he by then had a reputation as a
formidable soldier
so in a way
even though he eventually lost his
little fleet he slowed them down enough
so that they had they did not take
ticonderoga they didn't even attack
ticonderoga when they finally got down
there
and they turned and went back and a week
after they went back the lake started to
freeze over they just made it out of
there or they would have been stranded
in the winter so people have given him a
lot of credit
for building the fleet and for that
battle that he fought that two-day naval
battle that he fought with that vastly
out man vastly outgunned and he was able
to just slow them down and take enough
you know do enough damage to really give
them something to think about and as a
result they didn't come when was his
first uh
day in the military
i think it was when he went well no he
was what year was it oh well in 75 right
away because even before lexington and
concord a lot of the towns throughout
the colonies were raising militia troops
and they were drilling on the green and
doing all this and arnold joined the
militia troop i mean he was instrumental
in founding the militia troop in new
haven and was elected its captain which
was a great mark of prestige in the in
the community it meant that his men
regarded him
well and the men at lexington news of
lexington and concord came in april of
75
he said okay boys let's go
and most of them went with him they
didn't have to but some most of them did
and they marched up to cambridge
where they
met the continental army such as it was
i mean washington hadn't even been
appointed commander there wasn't any
continental army it was basically local
militias who after the british had
gotten back into lexington and concord
and all that blood had been spilled on
that terrible two days they were holed
up in washington in boston
surrounded in all the suburbs by this
ragtag little group of local militias
and arnold just wanted to go up and help
all right let me take
back to the lexington and concord 1775
what happened at lexington and concord
in massachusetts okay the british
knew
that the the continentals the colonials
had some military stores at concord
and they decided the british commander
in boston general gage decided that he
had to go out there and either take them
bring them away or destroy them
boston was a powder keg at this point
the boston massacre it occurred there
were british troops stationed in the
city and everybody was very very jittery
so gage decided to go to concord to
capture these stores and bring them back
or as i say destroy them and this was
when paul revere made his famous ride of
warning people how the british were
coming and what road they were taking
and all that
so they marched up towards concord which
is you know west of boston not very many
miles
and when they got to lexington green
which is the town just before concord
there was the local militia
arranged on the green
and the local militia commander had no
intention of trying to stop them because
he was vastly outmanned but he just
wanted to get out there to let them know
that the colonials were not sleeping and
the colonials were not going to let them
buy without some kind of show
so the british commander stopped his
troops and they faced each other for a
few minutes and finally the british
commander said you must disperse or risk
the consequences and they were in the
process of dispersing
when a shot was fired and nobody knows
who fired it
but
somebody fell down dead and there was a
battle i think there were
well it was fewer than 10 colonials who
were hurt there and i don't belie are
killed and i don't believe any british
were hurt but maybe i'm not i'm not
absolutely sure it was a tiny amount so
the british anyway kept going towards
concord but of course the minute word
got out in the countryside that this had
happened at lexington green and that
people had been killed everybody started
gathering so they got by the time they
got to conquer the british
and and destroyed the stores and pack
them up and brought them back or
whatever they did but the minute they
turned around and headed back for boston
here they were not not so much
confronted but they were marching down
roads with stone walls on either side
and behind every stone of those walls
there was a sniper and they had a
horrendous time they were picked off by
the hundreds
and uh eventually by the time they got
back to lexington gage had sent out
reinforcements just because he was
afraid something might happen he hadn't
heard yet but even so they they had a
terrible terrible day and evening
getting themselves back into boston so
that was the first blood and it was it
was an accident as far as anybody knows
what was the relationship between the
colonials the continental army and the
british troops at that point
in other words did any americans serve
in the british army oh a lot of them had
oh during the french george washington
made his reputation
uh and he was he was with general
braddock in that disastrous march down
in virginia during the french and indian
wars uh horatio gates had served in the
french and indian wars philip schuyler
oh they all had anybody who knew
anything about warfare had learned it
from the british
so in that the british army at that time
could have been at that moment could
they also have been
americans
yeah washington i mean none of them was
in the british
the the the british troops in boston
were not colonials they were british
redcoats so they were not they would not
have been colonial troops in other words
there would have been no men of
conquered fighting against other men of
conquered no and benedict arnold born in
this country
on his way to cambridge is a part of the
new haven militia let's go boys
absolutely so he guts to cambridge
and he manages to introduce himself to a
man named joseph warren who was a doctor
who was a member of the same masonic
lodge as paul revere which is the
masonic lodge that is widely believed to
have perpetrated the tea party and
arnold was a mason and the masons in the
colonies every if you were mason you
went to another town and you
automatically were accepted
you know by the other masons who tended
to be not only the social leaders and
the uh financial leaders but the um but
the intellectual leaders
what was a mason uh a freemason you know
that
organization started in in france and uh
it was it was anti-catholic and it was
anti-autocratic i mean they were great
believers in individual rights and great
believers in thomas paine and the rights
of man and all that only men so oh yeah
i'm sure
so this is where arnold i think picked
up a lot of his rhetoric he had very
good rhetoric but i think this is where
he picked up a lot of his patriotic
rhetoric was from being a mason
but anyway he gets to he gets to
cambridge and he manages to meet joseph
warren and joseph warren is the head of
the massachusetts committee of safety
there is a massachusetts committee of
safety a massachusetts committee of
correspondence and massachusetts
assembly all these little the
ambassador's assembly was official but
all these other little ad hoc
organizations that sprang up to
articulate grievances against great
britain anyway
warren managed to
get a massachusetts colonel arnold was a
connecticut captain
and warren was able to create him a
massachusetts colonel
and to send him with a commission from
the massachusetts committee of safety to
capture fort ticonderoga and to get the
art and to send the artillery that was
there back to boston
so that the so that the continentals
would have artillery to blast the
british out of the city because they of
course they had no artillery the brits
had all the the british had all the
artillery artillery
so he races off to do this but of course
he gets halfway there and finds out that
somebody else is in front of him and
that ethan allen's already there ready
to capture ticonderoga and uh arnold
being arnold instead of saying oh well
that's wonderful i'll help you
flash is his commission in front of
these six or eight men who would
organize the whole thing were ready to
go in their boats and says fine i have
an official commission i will now be the
commander of this and they looked at him
and said
no you won't
and he said yes i will well by the end
of it he and alan
said that they would be joint commercial
commanders although they loathed each
other but i think by the end of it words
had been spoken by him
he made implacable enemies among those
men i think he had that talent he could
be very charming very gracious i mean he
was well educated he was gently reared
all that but if you crossed him
i have a feeling he had an ability to
make a min to make an enemy in about 30
seconds flat in this he would be about
34 yeah 75 was he married he was married
he had three
children first wife like she was her
name was margaret mansfield her father
was the i believe the high sheriff of
new haven county he was a very
prosperous merchant trader he married up
he married well
um i don't know what the marriage was
like all we all i know is that he when
he was on trading voyages would
constantly write to her and say
please just one letter i don't know if
you guys are all right or not i don't
know whether i'm writing to the living
or the dead
she appears to have not been enormously
affectionate let's put it that way
how did mail move around because you
talk a lot about mail uh well of course
when he was in the caribbean he would
send it back probably with a ship
captain that he knew who would then
arrange to have it personally delivered
to her i mean there certainly wasn't any
postal service it was all done through
ships and and
riders and things and individual
couriers and in those days how do they
communicate in other words in the middle
of a war like this well that was part of
the trouble of course they didn't very
reliably i mean they sent individual
couriers military couriers would go back
and forth between but they they weren't
in very close touch
which led to the commanders in the
fields having enormous latitude
because washington as commander-in-chief
could be down in pennsylvania and
horatio gates in arnold would be up
fighting at saratoga and there was no
way washington was going to be able to
say yes attack no don't attack they had
to make their decisions their decisions
on the field which of course if they won
and were successful they got all the
credit but if they lost and were
unsuccessful they got all the blame
what was the last uh biography of ben
benedict arnold that you saw that of any
relevance before you wrote this um there
flexner james t flexner wrote one in the
60s i believe there was one published
about two years ago but at that point i
was right in the middle of writing this
and i was in fact
more finished than not finished if the
willards turn round yes and i didn't
read it because i i just thought what i
don't need now is another influence i
mean i i'm really so much into my own
book here that i think it would be
unhealthy for me to read that i would
like to read it now and i will that i'm
finished because i understand it's a
good book and he's a very nice man but
uh i have not read it but that that's
the most recent what makes you think a
book on benedict arnold's cell
because i think people are interested in
him i think people are interested in
traitors especially after mr ames the
other day
and i think this what this book does
well the reason i wrote this book and
didn't
let the other books deter me from
writing it was that to my satisfaction
nobody had really explained why he did
it
i had to know
more about this man and what
how he could encompass all these
contradictions in his character i wanted
to know what tipped him over i i had the
feeling i mean everybody says oh he did
it for the money which indeed he did
everybody says he did it because he was
badly mistreated by congress which
indeed he was everybody says he was very
discouraged because civilian support for
the war was waning rapidly which indeed
it was
but every other officer in the
continental army was in exactly the same
situation and felt exactly the same way
the same angers the same frustrations
but he's the only one
who turned his coat
and i wanted to know what it was and the
minute i began to do the research i said
there's something really personal about
this man
he did this for very personal reasons
and i want to try to figure out what
those are so that's what i did where'd
you spend most of your time
at home in front of the computer
but uh i did research well in london i
went to philadelphia of course and i did
travel around to all the battle sites
there's a wonderful repository of
american documents at ann arbor at the
clements library at the university of
michigan
uh they bought i think it was in the 40s
i think they thought they were buying
sir henry clinton was the british
commander-in-chief in new york at the
time of arnold's treason
they heard i think this is a story they
told me out there that his
his war his trunk that he took around
with him was for sale
at an auction in london and they bought
it sighed unseen
shipped it back to ann arbor opened the
trunk and inside of it was all the
correspondence
between arnold on the one hand and
clinton and major andre on the other
hand during the tr during the time of
the treason all the intelligence he was
sending up until that time nobody had
seen any of this and up until that time
nobody had known that his wife was
involved but clearly from the from the
documents she is her second this is his
second wife peggy peggy
yes and what year was that discovered
was this trunk i think it was in the 40s
maybe the 50s maybe right after world
war ii i'm not absolutely sure of the
year
but that once that came to light
obviously arnold scholarship was sort of
given a whole new dimension now there
have been books since then but i still
felt that nobody really got down to it
and figured out why this man did what he
did and that's that that was my goal for
myself
uh you say you retraced all these steps
how did you physically do that how did
you get a boat or
airplane
following my nose asking around when i
went up to lake champlain um i can't
even oh well there's a there's a lake
champlain maritime museum and i uh got
in touch with the director up there
well i knew somebody who knew the
director of crown point and he said oh
you must call so and so so i called so
and so and he said oh well this is the
person to take you out on a boat so it's
just a question of following your nose
and making a lot of phone calls and
setting it up before you go but going
out on a boat in lake champlain was just
wonderful because you you can understand
how that battle went so much of it
depended on the wind and on the
maneuverability of the ships and i got
out there in a sailing boat one one boat
at the northern end won the southern end
and realized the minute i got out there
of course this was incredibly difficult
because it's surrounded by mountains
and the sailing is very very tricky and
there's there they're wonderful visual
things i was there in october when he
fought the battle of valcour island um
little miss that appear would make all
the islands seem to float and things
like that in which you just i don't
think you can get that kind of thing
until you actually go
one other thing you sent me uh on a
little uh side trip when i read the
footnote that
that the the philadelphia the gondola
boat is at the smithsonian yeah so i had
to go down and say yes myself isn't it
wonderful how did you find how did you
know that uh i think they told me up at
lake champlain i think that's where i
first learned about and of course i came
down to see it
but um you did make a trip just to see
it down no i think i probably combined
it with something else with a research
trip or whatever but um oh sure i had to
see what it was like
absolutely and what what is the
philadelphia it it was it was one of the
gondolas at the battle of valcour island
in
october of 1776. uh it was the first of
the american ships i think to go down
and it he was the the ships were drawn
up in a line between the island and the
mainland and as the british beat back up
towards them as i explained they came
sort of one and two at a time and the
americans tried to stick together and
just throw everything they could at them
they didn't have a whole lot and the
philadelphia was hit
and and sank um i think she's i think
she was hit in the afternoon and then
sank after dark do you remember i'm
trying to remember what i read on the on
the little notes there what year they
brought that ship up no i'm afraid i
don't it's not that long no no it's not
that long ago they they sent divers down
and got her and arnold's flagship is
still at the bottom of ferris bay when
when the battle was over and he'd
finally escape with a few ships but knew
he couldn't get all the way down to
crown point uh and the british were
right on his tail just coming right down
at him these three huge ships after
these little tiny sort of ducklings
going along in the in the lake he turned
he managed to get himself into a a bay
which has a relatively narrow opening
and scuttle all of his ships and burn
them
and his ship and then they made their
way uh by land down to crown point he
and the few men that were left um his
ship is still down at the bottom of the
mud there and divers go and visit it all
the time i gather it's very very stiff
mud and they may never be able to raise
it up and and why not leave it there
anyway i mean it's kind of a nice
tribute i think to him from your
experience how do we do as a country
when it comes to either archives or
research libraries or things like the
smithsonian very well very well i've
i've been very impressed the library of
congress is wonderful to work at the
national archives is
very helpful uh research libraries all
over the country in new york of course
historical society of philadelphia new
haven colony they're terrific
and it's it's fun to go to places
because you can always find somebody
there who's interested in what you're
doing and if you can't find it in the
card catalog they'll say oh well i think
i know something you'd be interested in
and they lead you down a little card or
into a dusty stack and show you some
wonderful treasure they're they're dying
to have people come and work at there
and they're they're terribly helpful i
think we do i think we do very well let
me just ask you about a couple things in
the bibliography and i want to ask you
if you saw this stuff here i hope i can
tell you
here's here's just one listing minutes
of the provincial council and supreme
executive council of pennsylvania 16
volumes harrisburg 1838 to 1853 have you
been through that i haven't been through
all of it but i've been through the
parts that pertain to arnold sure where
do you find something like that uh
actually that is in the vassar college
library which is near where i live
and those those minutes are there and
then and the um
yeah i'm pretty sure that's where i got
that i mean it's a printed source a lot
of libraries have it you said you took
six years on this book how many days a
week would you work on it oh five
i when i'm doing research i mean i you
know if i go on a trip i work as many
days as the libraries are open um when
i'm home
i work five days a week starting at
eight o'clock in the morning until i
can't stand it anymore and sometimes
that's well i make myself sit there for
three hours no matter what
even if nothing's coming into my head if
nothing's happening um
i'll go longer if
if it's coming out and if it's if it's
all working uh the research you can keep
going all day i can just getting it in
there and getting it organized and
mulling it over so what kind of mood
swings do you have through a project
like this over six years lord lots and
lots and lots do you ever want to give
up no
because i was just too interested and i
really really wanted to tell this story
but there there are very difficult
moments moments where you think you're
never going to get a handle on it you
know you you end up with
a bulging computer as it were with all
these little disparate items of
information and some of them you got
four years ago and you've practically
forgotten them and some of them you got
yesterday and you can't figure out where
in the world they fit they look like
they belong to a different jigsaw puzzle
and you shouldn't be bothering with them
at all
and until you get a handle on it it can
be very very difficult i always write a
first draft that has everything in it
and it reads about as interestingly as a
laundry list i mean first he did this
and he did this i just have a
chronological laundry list of everything
that happened to him and that he did on
every given day
and only after dealing with that and
wrestling with that
through at least you know through just
getting it down on the page which is a
chore
things murky shapes begin to appear
and that's then you just go with those
and you test them and make sure that
they work and before you finally decide
to use them it's it's really um it's
really a feeling in the dark for a while
and you and it can be discouraging
but i i always knew he was there
somewhere for me and so i i just was i
wasn't gonna let him go was there a
magic moment or two where yeah really
came together yeah uh there there was
there was a weird one on this book um
when arnold was the commandant in
philadelphia in 1778-79
when he was
courting peggy ship and madly in love
with her and of course her father wanted
him to have some money and things before
he would let her marry him he was also
leading a very high style of living in
the capital and
carriage horses and he'd moved into the
british common dance house and all that
and made himself pretty 17 68 69 no
1778-79 just after the british had
gotten out of they'd been in
philadelphia for a year
they
captured philadelphia after the battle
of brandywine in 77 and were there for a
year and then they got out i mean
voluntarily and the americans came back
in and arnold because he'd been so badly
wounded at saratoga and couldn't ride a
horse couldn't fight in the field so
washington gave him the job of being
common down to philadelphia
which was a terrible thing for arnold it
was just awful because it was it was it
demanded political acumen intact and all
those things he didn't have and didn't
have any action attached to it which is
what he really liked but anyway let me
just ask you what happened to his first
wife oh she was she died in
1775 while he was away at ticonderoga so
he's in philadelphia he's in
philadelphia he's been a widower for
three years
uh in the meantime though he had courted
a i think 15 year old in boston who had
turned him down just the best he's now
betsey dubois yeah
he's now 38 or 9
and peggy is 19.
and he just i think fell head over heels
and i think she fell head over heels in
love with him too because he was
sophisticated he was you know all this
and the great general arnold the patriot
hero i mean why not
um probably do you have a limp by the
way oh yes very much so very much so one
foot shorter than the other one yeah
well
he had the wound at saratoga was
obviously hideous and it wouldn't heal
and wooden heel he was in the hospital
for something like three or four months
after that and it would get better and
then it would open up again and he was
having operation after operation and
taking out bone chips and i mean it was
just grisly
so he finally got to valley forge
in the in the early spring of 78 just as
the british were about to get out of
philadelphia and washington just took
one look at him and realized of course
that he was not about to be able to take
a command in the field
and and so gave him gave him uh
philadelphia instead
so he went in there
philadelphia was
was
of all of the big cities of the colonies
i think philadelphia probably had the
highest proportion of tories
who of course had all been having a
wonderful time while the british were
there for years what's a tory
in that time a british sympathizer a
person who thought we should not be an
independent country
and uh
so when the british left a lot of a lot
of philadelphia tories went with them
one of the reasons it took them about
three weeks to get out of town is that i
think 3 000 philadelphians went with
them to new york
but the wigs then came back into
philadelphia and particularly the
radical whigs the american patriots as
they would have themselves were of
course
pretty angry if the tories had been
having a high total time with the
british and there was a very kind of
vigilante atmosphere in philadelphia it
was very ugly
uh and arnold sort of stepped into this
and as i say he was not a tactful man he
was and he certainly had no political
skills
and he
he liked women he liked high living he
liked beautiful houses he liked good
food and nice wine and he just sort of
fell in with a lot of tories including
peggy shippen now her peggy sheppan's
father had never declared himself one
way or the other but he'd been a fence
sitter and he had been in fact confined
to the state of pennsylvania by the
authorities during the war because he
was a very he was a suspected tory
and one of these vigilante whigs who
turned out to be the head of the
government of the state of pennsylvania
glommed in on arnold and and just
decided that he was a closet tory
and hated him really conceived a true
hatred for this man it was his name his
name was joseph reed
uh who had been an aide to camp to
washington at the beginning of the war
blah blah blah but he was a quaker and
he was a
radical whig and he was head of the
government of the state of pennsylvania
and he made arnold's life miserable
but here's arnold um
doing a number by the by this time he
was very short of cash and he really
needed it in order to woo and marry
peggy
he was already engaged in a number of
private money-making schemes
which were ethically if not legally
suspect shall we say
and reed glommed onto a couple of these
things and started nosing around and
doing investigations and and publishing
broadsides in the paper about what a
rotten guy benedict arnold was
so here's arnold
madly in love wanting money desperate
for money not making much
all these wonderful schemes he had could
have made him a lot of money they never
made him a penny
at the same time
he is sending money to boston
to
support and educate the children of dr
joseph warren the man who had sent him
to taconderoga in the first place
now arnold hardly knew warren and why in
the world
was he sending money which he didn't
really think he had
to support these kids and i couldn't
figure this out and i looked in some
other biographies and they sort of
relegated it to a footnote and said well
i guess he wasn't such a bad guy after
all you know but it kept gnawing at me
and i kept saying this doesn't fit but
what is arnold trying to tell me here
and then i finally said wait a minute
support and education
that's exactly what his father failed to
provide for him
and then i remembered that during the
during the early days before the war
during his first marriage when he was
off on trading voyages he was constantly
writing to his wife uh and knowing that
she was being done by creditors and
worried about her and all that and
saying do this do that pay that bill
don't pay this bill
but he said over and over again and when
i first read these i didn't understand
it be sure that our children get
educated it is of the utmost important
he wrote to her about this almost
obsessively and given his value system
which didn't really include education
particularly i mean he didn't like it he
didn't care for it for his own sake he
wasn't a great reader or a great scholar
i thought that was kind of queer
well the minute i realized
about the warren children and then
thought back to his own childhood it
suddenly wasn't queer at all anymore
this kid had really been traumatized by
the fact that the rug had been pulled
out from under him when he was a kid
i mean it suddenly began to add up
and then when i kind of extrapolated
from that the other effects that that
kind of childhood upheaval has on people
a lot of things begin to make sense
the fact that he could not brook any
criticism the fact that he was
desperately always worried about money
and not so much for its own sake but
because he felt that money was a sign
that the world regarded him highly that
it valued him and he needed it for that
reason as much as for the money itself
he needed people to say to him benedict
you're wonderful he needed security he
needed financial security and he needed
security of status he didn't ever want
anybody to come along again and say you
are no longer a prosperous trader son
you are an apothecaries apprentice he
didn't want that ever to happen again
and he was terrified that it would at
what moment did he become a traitor
he became a traitor to the united states
of america within two weeks of his
wedding to peggy shippen
when he wrote a letter he sent an
emissary into new york offering his
services to the british what year was
this 79. so 78 excuse me may of 17.
where was he he was in philadelphia he's
still commandant
just married
just married just married she sent a
letter to a letter to sir henry clinton
the british commander-in-chief in new
york city how'd you get that letter time
there was a china
dealer named joseph stansberry living in
philadelphia who was a purveyor of fine
china to philadelphia high society
obviously peggy shippen knew this guy
he was a tory she must have known that
anyway i can't believe that she didn't
tell him how to send it and she would
also told him who to send it to which
was not necessarily sir henry himself it
would have been hard to get to him but
to major john andre who was sir henry's
aide de camp
and by the way although they may not
have known it at the time sir henry
spymaster
so stansberry gets to new york and goes
to meet with andre and offers arnold's
services and from then on there is
correspondence there are letters that
went back and forth they were all
written in cipher
or with interlining you know that you
put lemon juice on or held over a candle
or something to find it and through and
then there were there were regular there
i mean there were there were various
couriers and and sort of go-betweens as
the thing went on over 18 months what
had benedict arnold asked the british
for he first said that what he wanted to
do was just to come over he wanted to
come over and become a british major
general and i think he probably thought
that that would be such a terrible
devastating psychological blow
that the whole american war effort would
crumble and he could win the war for the
british he actually had some very good
ideas of how to win the war for the
british if they listened to him they
might have won what did they say to him
they said no they said yes we're very
interested this is wonderful
but it would be much more useful to us
to have you stay where you are for the
moment send us intelligence
and if you can get command of a wing of
the army and make sure that we get it or
get command of an important post and
make sure that we capture it but let's
talk about this dear boy
but at one point here arnold wrote to
sir henry clinton and said if you will
tell me your plans for the coming
campaign
then i will be able to send you more
appropriate information and sir henry
wrote back
via major andre and said
i don't have to tell you anything
you just find out as much as you can
you're the one who approached us now you
prove yourself and then maybe we'll talk
about what you're going to do well
arnold couldn't stand it because of
course that was exactly the way he felt
that his own country when we're treating
him and that's exactly why he wanted to
go over to the british so i think this
is why later on he put major andre in
jeopardy and ended up getting major
andre hanged i think he he deliberately
did a couple of things that put major
andre's life on the line major andre was
hanged by whom by behanged by the
american army in front of the army at
tappan because he was a spy he was
caught behind lines
in disguise and after philadelphia where
did benedict arnold go all right after
he he finally resigned his as as
commandant and then he did begin to get
better he was able finally to ride a
horse and by this time he was
negotiating with the british and by this
time the british were very interested in
west point
so they where is west point it's in it's
about probably
50 miles north of new york city in the
huds on the hudson river the hudson
river goes almost straight north of new
york city
and then it goes through these series of
corkscrew turns around the mountains
called the highlands
and in order to sail up through the
highlands
it's very very difficult sailing and of
course those vessels in those days
didn't sail as well as ours do now
anyway
so in order to get upriver british ships
had to go through the highlands and the
americans had put a chain across in the
middle of the highlands earlier in the
war which the british had been able to
break
so they chose west point for the next
place to put a chain because there's an
s curve there
and it was almost 180 degrees the first
part of it and in order to the british
would not be able to break the chain the
argument went because in the course of
making that turn they would have to
reset their sails
and virtually stop in the water and then
they wouldn't have the momentum to break
the chain and meanwhile while they were
sitting there is sitting ducks all the
batteries up at west point up above on
the bluff would be able to blast them
out of the water so it was very
important
west point to the to the american
strategy of keeping the british out of
the hudson valley and protecting the
main
crossing king's ferry which was a few
miles to the south which washington
desperately desperately needed
so arnold and peggy go after west point
and she manages a few little finaglings
on her own
and arnold then goes and rejoins
washington he hasn't been promised it
yet but he's told the british that he
has it
and he then goes to join the army at uh
they were just across the hudson a
little bit north i guess up around nyack
so well tapping which is where they
ended up a few weeks later and um
they get he gets there and washington
says well we've sort of changed our
strategy we are not going to have an
inactive campaign and therefore i'm not
going to give you west point i want you
we're going to attack new york and i
want you to lead the left wing of the
army well this was a terrific honor
and arnold sort of blushed and fumbled
and stamped around and said well yes sir
of course but then the next day
washington got intelligence about some
british movements that made him call off
the attack on new york which actually
were an indirect result of some
intelligence that arnold had sent in
to
new york
and called off the attack and said well
if you really want west point that badly
i'll give it to you
and that's when he got it which was on
august the 3rd and on august the 21st he
met with major andre i mean september
the 21st he met with major andre and
four days later the whole thing blew so
he was there less than two months
so
the um
there's a part in the book where you
talk about
george washington coming to see him
coming to seeing benedict arnold at west
point and then he gets out of there yeah
um yeah that was tell that story amazing
well
major andre had been captured
after andre had come up river and met
with arnold and arnold had put him in a
position where he had to go behind
american lines and where he had to
be in disguise and he's his contact with
the british yes he's his contact with
the british and he then goes back to
new york but he has to go overland
because his ship has gone down river but
it's a long story but anyway and british
control manhattan the british control
manhattan westchester county which is
basically between west point and
manhattan is sort of a no man's land
controlled by nobody with a lot of
roving bands of irregulars on both sides
it's a very dangerous territory but this
is where arnold sends major andre to
make his way back to new york
so andre is stopped
by some irregulars he could have talked
his way out of it really quite easily
but he didn't think fast enough
and they made him take his clothes off
so they could search him and in his boot
they found
plans for the attack on west point in
arnold's handwriting which again arnold
had insisted andre take back to new york
with him there was no reason for him to
be carrying those plans he could have
memorized that easily but arnold
insisted it because he wanted a paper
trail to prove what he'd done to the
british to get his money i think but
anyway these guys found the papers and
meanwhile andre was behaving very
foolishly he was saying i'll give you my
gold watch if you'll let me go well that
was too much i mean they they somehow
got wind of the fact that they had
something important on their hands so
they turned him over to the american the
local american common commander at the
local
post
who turns out to have been a rather
mule-headed and not terribly bright man
who looked at these documents and looked
at major andre
and said well
these are in general arnold's
handwriting which of course he
recognized he said i guess i better send
the documents to general washington who
at this point was on his way back from
connecticut to the main army in in new
york in in tappan new york
he'd been over in connecticut meeting
with the french and he's on his way back
so
so this this idiot
in westchester county says i'm going to
send the papers to general washington
because he ought to see these and figure
out what's going on but meanwhile i will
send you
mr john anderson which was the name that
andre was using
up to my commander and he can dispose of
you as he will well of course his
commander was benedict arnold and andre
thought he was saved
so it was a dark and stormy night indeed
literally when major andre was taken on
his horse was the guard obviously up
towards west point well while he's on
his way
into the idiot commander's headquarters
a few miles below where andre is at this
point so so here's the headquarters
andre is heading north the courier is
heading east to try to find washington
with the papers and into the idiots
headquarters comes a
major of dragoons called benjamin
talmadge
who theoretically was the under officer
to this idiot
but
major talmage also happened to be the
head of general washington's secret
service
and when he heard about the papers
and heard about what this man had done
he said you
crashing idiot
why did you do this obviously there's
something going on here that we ought
so he insisted that his superior officer
in fact send for major andre and bring
him back
but the man insisted on sending another
courier ahead up to arnold to tell him
what had happened
meanwhile washington's coming back by a
different route so the papers don't
catch up to washington
but arnold sits down to breakfast the
next morning and gets a letter from the
guy down below saying we have captured a
mr john anderson carrying incriminating
papers
and the papers have been sent to general
washington
and he puts that note down and gets
another note immediately saying general
washington is on his way here to
breakfast he was expecting him for
breakfast that morning he's he's
examining a few red doubts up above here
and he'll be here in 10 minutes
and andre arnold of course thinks
it's over i mean he has the papers he
knows he's going to get me
so he raced upstairs to his wife who was
having breakfast in bed
tells her obviously what's happened very
quickly dashes downstairs jumps on his
horse goes to the bottom of the hill and
jumps in his barge he has a he has a
barge with eight bargemen down there
that rowing because he he's across the
river from west point living in a house
off the point they of course start to
row up towards west point and he says no
you idiots down river because he thinks
that the ship that brought major andre
up river is probably waiting for him
down in haverstraw bay and his only
chance of getting away is to get to that
ship
so he orders them to row and they wrote
i figured an incredible amount my
daughter used to be a rower and we
figured out with the tides and
everything they for an hour and a half
got him there
safely
uh leaving peggy of course behind
and then he got to the ship and
came in under her guns with a white flag
a little white handkerchief on the top
of his bayonet um
this is a british this was a british
ship right uh told the people on board
what had happened of course they were
sitting there waiting for major andre
and they said where in the world is he
and andre said well he's been captured
and they say oh my god you know this is
terrible well before he left
before they sailed back down to new york
arnold wrote a letter to general
washington
who by this time of course had gotten
the papers and didn't know what was
happening
a letter which began
the heart that is conscious of its own
rectitude cannot attempt to paleate a
step which the world may censure is
wrong
the guy had hutzpah if nothing else he
never admitted that he'd done anything
wrong he never admitted that he was a
traitor
he never admitted anything not till the
day he died
benedict arnold went
to england when
at the uh he he went to new york first
he then went on an expedition for the
british down to virginia and he then
fought he went up and attacked new
london connecticut he went to england a
couple of months after yorktown
so december 81
and he got there in january he got to
london in january of 82. how long did he
live in
oh until 1801 20 years almost 20 years
miserable miserable 20 years because of
course the brits didn't like him either
he was a traitor and he was a failed
traitor they wouldn't give him a job
they wouldn't give him a commission in
the army they wouldn't do anything for
him he had to go to canada to try to set
himself up as a merchant and trader and
that didn't work out
and
he went to when he went to canada nova
scotia uh new brunswick new brunswick
new brunswick you said he had a mistress
there yeah his wife wasn't with him no
she wasn't with him for the first couple
of years and a baby he had an
illegitimate son there yes but his wife
found out well i think she has to have
he then went to england and got her and
the other kids it was a tiny town i
can't believe she didn't find out i
don't know that she did but i can't
believe she didn't what year did he die
1801 of what
um you know this is embarrassing because
i got a doctor to tell me what he
thought it was from the contemporary
descriptions and i now can't remember
they called it a general dropsy and a
disease in the lungs it was obviously
something respiratory um
and he couldn't lie down and get
comfortable it and i think i think it
was something in the lungs but i can't
remember now what do you think of this
guy
i think he was a rotten traitor myself
but i think he's a hell of an
interesting man wonderful character
i feel sorry for him in a way except
that he brought it on himself but he was
totally lacking in self-knowledge you
have to have some compassion i think for
a person who really is
totally self-deluded about himself and
about the world who doesn't let reality
in at all
it's interesting
uh it's not very admirable
but you have to have a little spasm of
pity here and there for him i think in
history how does he fit with our other
traitors
um
i don't think he does really very well i
i think i mean if you look at the cold
war traders the early ones a lot of them
were doing it for ideological reasons
and i don't think
arnold didn't have an ideological bone
in his body
i think he's much closer to mr ames i
think the money question is much closer
but i think i wouldn't be surprised if
mr ames didn't also have some very very
personal reasons for having done this if
you read a little bit that we've all
been reading about his career i can see
where there's a lot of disappointment
possibly i think there may be some
parallels also mr ames got in touch with
the russians the same year he was
married to his second much younger wife
he died at age 60 how did he leave his
wife and kids
in debt
up to their ears living in a grand
lavish house with a wine cellar and
servants and a carriage and horses and
the whole thing and in debt up to their
ears by this time their oldest son was
in india in the army
but the others were really quite young
there were three more boys and a girl
and mrs arnold peggy who had stuck by
him all this time and had never admitted
to anybody that there was anything the
matter the she called him the best of
husbands
she took hold
she sold the house she sold the wine
cellar she put the whole thing up for
auction bought a few things back herself
established herself in a tiny little
house in bryanson street
no carriage no horses nothing
wrote letters to a friend saying there
are people who've been snubbing me
because i don't have what i did have
before and i can't arrive at their tea
parties and carriages but so what i i
know who my real friends are now and i
don't have a single item in this house
that i haven't paid for myself
and she
managed to arrange for all the children
to be
educated she got the younger boys into
military academies and things
and then got cancer of the woman died
about three or four years after he did
but she was some woman
smart
tough
very intelligent
wonderful lady we're about out of time
can you tell us what this means
oh that's my husband and my three
children
why did you do it with letters i don't
know for fun
what are their names uh carl is my
husband cameron's my stepson and colin
and diana are my son and daughter
can i write another book oh you bet
about what
aaron burr and alexander hamilton i want
to know about that duel
here's the book the man in the mirror is
the name of it claire brandt is the
author and it's the life of benedict
arnold thank you very much thank you
the redesigned booknotes website now
features over 800 notable